so first of all really sorry about
missing my slot
I was actually downstairs trying to cram
a few more slides and totally lost track
of time
and there's a reason for that is that
I'm actually really nervous to talk to
you I'm normally not nervous to talk to
crowds but you guys represent my actual
peers I've been dealing with data in New
York for almost a decade now I hope I
don't know if any of my old colleagues
here I used to help run their Hadoop
meetup in town and it was back when we
were just like getting the crumbs from
the west coast and like if you're
running a Hadoop cluster using open
source data you were like really new
yeah you were like really new and it was
like a lonely time to kind of manage big
data when you had all these banks and
there are tons of money to throw it like
huge clusters of stuff and we kind of
like ended up growing the community to
the time that it's a size like this so
it's it's kind of a I fear your
judgments but I'm like honored because
we're all struggling with the same
things often like one building away from
each other so I hope you can take
advantage of this also like shout out to
Pete and Adam it's not easy to organize
introverts into a community and Pete's
trying to make a business out of it
so thanks for shuffling your like
expense accounts his way because I think
like the community helps anyways
I work in the New York Times now which
is I swear to God like the most
interesting place to work like not even
during election seasons but like even
under normal times and I hope that's
going to come across a bit I know that
my company's more interesting than I
will ever be so I'll just start with
what it's like to work there and the
things I see and then they may we'll get
into some of the details but my goal
here is to connect let's say that the
times the business that's in drill down
through how that turns into day into
data problems what is the difference
between like data science as exhibition
sports and data science as we need to do
this to thrive some of you working like
funded companies rerunning on kind of
runway we're you know undergoing a sea
change in terms of our revenue model and
I'll have some plots to show you exactly
what that is
from like a quarterly report down to
actual projects that we work on and then
how the data infrastructure has at times
gotten in our way and how it's helped us
and what how we're trying to deal with
it hang on a sec there we go all right
so this is the newsroom
The Times moved into a new building
about a decade ago
it's like right across the street from
Port Authority and the newsroom is
actually its own almost separate
building this is pretty intentional oh
let me go back for a second so this is
pretty intentional because they kind of
want a separation between the news and
the business which is almost cute in
like romantic in this day and age one of
the things about being there is that you
need can't just buy software off the
shelf everything that other newspapers
end up doing we often have to try first
and we spend enormous amount of time
like doing things that don't end up
working NYC narrow you know we ended up
killing even though I thought it was a
fantastic gap but the the way you scroll
through news we recognize we learned a
lot about mobile on that and a lot of
the way that you interact within righty
now made its way into the regular mobile
app our CFO I think recently made a
quote that print journalism is gonna
outlast desktop web but mobile is
probably the way that all of us are
going to get our news for now in the
foreseeable future and we have days
where our CTO says everybody just used
the mobile you know device to look at
the web because that's how people are
seeing it this model is very different
from the organization of a newsroom
these these are actually organized in
rows called desks and yet like the
sports desk the business desk etc and
these are ways of making a newspaper
that are almost 100 years old and many
of the ways that other newspapers have
come to to produce the product is based
on things that the New York Times did
almost a hundred years ago just to put
it in context we're older than the Civil
War like when you go into the company
there's like a bust of a guy and his
great-great-great-great grandson is like
a product manager your company I'll get
into the family in a sec however there
is a separation
so we we've always had a tech wing and
it's always been you know no one else is
doing it can't buy it off the shelf this
is our CMS maybe you still like Drupal
or blog stuff but not many CMS's have
like full layout capability and this has
become really crucial because now we
have to output the multi platforms
previously what we did is we basically
repurposed the Prince MIT material for
mobile and web but now we're kind of
have a mobile-first attitude like a lot
of people so we have to think
simultaneously how is this story going
to read on like seven different devices
we also produce newsroom tools some of
the my colleagues are here and in this
this is nice and slick we actually use
this internally but you can see even
from the numbers here this is basically
how people are getting to the app to our
stories a lot of it comes from social
and search now and there are lots of
people in newsroom who you know grew up
during a pure paper era so getting them
to adapt to kind of this way of thinking
is often a cultural issue in the company
I'm going to show how culture impacts
your data infrastructure in a second we
had eight Emmy nominations last year
that's something we didn't have like a
real video department as if five years
ago and we're trying to figure out you
know we have our D that kind of looks at
what news is going to mean in the future
and again all these are like expensive
people money losing efforts but nobody's
gonna do it but us I'm not gonna say
which publication it was but there was
one publication that were recently
admitted to us that they were flirting
with a payroll but they wanted to see
what was gonna happen first and we took
a dive on a paywall
remember wired everybody was saying okay
wall will kill your business you don't
understand you media finalized the pay
wall is words but it took four years for
us to make that decision and when we did
it other companies got there kind of
motivation to take a chance on it all
this say we're often out first with with
the stuff and everyone has a bit of this
kind of rebellious spirit recently you
probably saw this I mean those are our
lawyers and so there's a bit of like
kick ass that you have to have in like
many areas of the times just to like get
your agenda through but I'm like proud
to work at a place like that it's a
public company profit is not its only
motive and this plays everyday in all
our
decisions I don't think the family would
want to change the nature of the paper
if we had to cave an entire liter market
demands and abandon our mission not sure
like that's what they're here for if you
get born into the Salzburg family you
can almost imagine it like you're part
of a tribe of knights who are there to
guard the sanctity of an institution so
if you're David Perpich or or any of the
any of the family who are in senior
positions around the time they're there
to guard the traditions of the paper and
figure out how to make it adapt for
survival in the world of all newspapers
I think we're best positioned of
traditional newspapers were really best
positions to write out kind of this
transition to digital but in your story
what that looks like it numbers in a
second first let's talk about is gonna
comp in a second but there's this whole
tradition of like really keeping the
business separate from the rest of the
organization and it's even reflect in
our architecture I'm gonna go I had one
second so this is the building this is
the newsroom where you know most of the
news gets made in a few of these floors
this is a tree an atrium of barriers and
then I work over here and I'm gonna show
you where our mainframes are they're
over there and I'll show you how we span
like 40 years of technology kind of
within the one company but we've
intentionally erected a Chinese wall
between the business interests in the
newspaper and the journalists and this
has served well for integrity reasons in
the past that it works against you
sometimes when you're trying to join
data sets and get people on the same
page with what their goals are this is
the this is the slide this is not us
only this is the entire news industry
some of you're at growth companies right
2008 was d-day that was when everybody
shifted to digital the crash affected us
except we did not recover on the print
side it's you know it print read
advertising revenues are going down we
all know print as eventually going away
but this is something I really get
amused that when people tell me that's
like it's news The Times has been
planning this for a long time and we
have a lot of good news in this area too
because it looks like people are
shifting their purchase to digital
subscriptions you know all
these pains are just my own you and the
camera if you're at home watching this
don't take this out of context I don't
want to speak on behalf of strategy for
The Times or anything like that I'm just
the guy in the building who's watching
this like you but we get scrutinized
more than anybody else I don't have to
make slides for my talk I can just go to
our competitors and pull all the numbers
that I need because every time we like
make any mood everybody covers it so
digital is more and more of our business
but you know a lot of our model our
revenue model is slowly slowly depleting
we just put out a quarterly report this
this week and I mean first of all we're
profitable we've generally been
profitable but 18% year of your decline
and something that's more than half your
revenue stream that's not a business
that can be complacent and the problem
is for a long time I think the New York
Times was at the top of this media heat
and it accrued some of the institutional
kind of inertia that happens when you
don't really have to innovate and now
it's like startup I came there with
startup mentality I came there with like
I need this thing done you know now and
today and there's like a there's a
subculture that in the times now that is
very vibrant but you're also you know
looking at an older institution some of
you maybe work at larger institutions
where these are like important battles
but it's really worth like making it
happen because these old institutions
have so much sway in the culture that
you get a lot more mileage by doing by
moving the needle at the times I think
than by going to like a smaller startup
and trying to get one of eighty people
turn off the ground I mean that's why
I'm there the unimportant thing is the
paywall
this is the thing that nobody said would
work we have 1.5 million 1.57 million
paid digital-only subscribers there was
no freebies those are like real people
paying real money and what really
discovered is that people want good
journalism we spent a lot of money
investing in new ways to tell stories
all of you seen the upshot it takes a
lot of people to put that stuff together
and we find as people actually pay for
it and what we're trying to figure out
is what happens as a new generation ages
inch there so this is our goal from
that our executive editor made a year
ago basically we have five years to
double digital revenue I'm not gonna say
if that's aggressive or not because
that's in the strategy territory but so
far the line looks good this was a
digital subscriber from the first time
we got the paywall right until 2015
these are the last three data points now
some of that is Trump this has been a
crazy news cycle and we know there's a
very strong correlation between people
just using the newspaper whatever their
interaction with is and clicking on a
purchase decision and one of the
challenges we have now is to figure out
how much of this is because invest
didn't we've made into the product
verses like this crazy news cycle all
right so then I'm gonna go to my story
bit I like a year worked in ads and you
know it's early and on the Hadoop and
the open source data movement and I
don't how to put this I just got bored
of it I got I'd seen my millions Hadoop
stack trace and I had dealt with a lot
of the data issues that I see per pet
perennially coming up time and time
again and I chose to shift into data
science so I went back to school and
then I got this gig at the time and this
is a picture of me in my first day at
work that's what you're told like the
job's gonna be right you're just gonna
you know you're gonna like lawn mower
man your way through all this stuff and
find the answers that nobody for some
reason has ever come up with it the
company because you know how to run with
just a progression it's not how it works
right but you know I got there and there
was a customer turn model that was in
pride so on the left is a name called
Boris Boris Chen networks of Netflix and
I know Boris he never would have left
the prod model running it at 0.5 AUC so
that means it's basically slightly
better than the coin flick at prick the
predicting who's gonna cancel so I'd
done a little digging into this thing
and really what turned out is you know
from a softer it is from a softer
background we have really strong
traditions for how to make something in
production
we're always essentially panicked that
everything's going to fail it every time
data science and a lot of people kind
data science now they just haven't spent
the years debugging production issues
and so really what happened is there was
tremendous data drift into the inputs
and the thing just started doing its
best but upstream our data sources had
changed how they code certain variables
and the it was just a random forest in
there and it was working the system was
up but it's producing crappy results I
really didn't do much to like move it to
there except like adjusted for the data
but it caused us to rethink what it
means to put out a data science a data
so first version one and I got a minute
at the Times we were still selling the
idea of data science there's a lot of
cultural work to be done so we got
something in production where we just
basically did a fit put its
characteristics what this turns into is
a bunch of email addresses that we mail
and it turns out when email people when
they're thinking of canceling you do get
a nice lift and they tend to not cancel
for a while but now we're like what are
we learned from this kind of production
failure again post mortem philosophy but
apply to data data systems one we
noticed that we need to figure out if
there's ever a shift in the underlying
data source if if we if a mean has
shifted you'd think like oh that's fine
your machine learning algorithm should
just adapt to that that's the whole
point of a machine learning algorithm
right so you don't have our core two
rules you should know if human behavior
customers is changing like very rapidly
like it's if your model is any good it
should survive you know slow shifts and
so we started just hard coding we put in
like hard-coded limits on what we think
like key variables should be being an
average mean and not mean and like nine
and sorry ten and like 90 percent
percentiles the other thing we started
doing is actually just running a small
cross cross-validation right in the fit
so the the program that does the fit it
does its own out-of-sample test it
outputs that as the statistic that we
log and we can see if something is
causing our model to get worse over time
and if it doesn't pass a certain
threshold of a you see we just don't
promote it
and the third thing is published
atomically you know and this is probably
you're used to if you're dealing with
data engineering issues you really don't
want to publish half a data set so
reengineering that so it was like a
smooth transition so as a data scientist
especially became from
from an academic or bootcamp backgrounds
you kind of like view these data
problems as being I got a data setting
implied technique to it and so this is
me kind of making that turn model and I
go to the people who requested in
marketing who are very concerned about
retaining customers I said great we got
this like 0.9 a you see like it's
essentially a crystal ball what have I
really done I've allowed them to figure
out who's gonna cancel and they had this
lever and this lever send them an email
great you know we get slightly more this
is only on the riskiest part of the
population but I haven't given them any
insight into why this is and I think
that's another difference between
working you know doing sample and toy
problems and then moving into the real
world is you're gonna interact with
people who maybe maybe they don't know
what algorithm you use they don't know
like the theory behind it but they know
their business and it's kind of like
strange that I know less I don't know
why this thing works to them that sounds
very odd to me you know black box is
black box but they're right to ask me
okay since you can predict tell me
something more about this is we need
some some real information to decide
what is a good strategy if we're gonna
make this big media buy we're going to
hire this person tell us something about
these customers that help you predict
well what should we do just rain so
these are all look at this these are
different methods that's random forest
that's l2 yeah it's it's that's just l2
logistic with l2 logistic survival and
this is like kind of increased the
yellow one until it's kind of the
variable drops off the l1 penalty look
at the rankings they're like all over
the place
every single technique thought something
different was important more or less
this is like not how it should work
on paper on paper all of these things
should have picked up the principal
components and said that's what's
important but this is real data so I
handed this to them and they rightfully
said what am I supposed to do at this
so it's a decision tree right this is
how you're gonna decide ever tried to
make a decision with the decision tree
and it says like less than 0.5 7 do this
and that you know it doesn't tell you
anything these things may work very well
but they're really hard for building
intuition around things ok so I knew
something was wrong here and the
statisticians in the room you know I'm
sure you're gonna like laugh at me for
this but I did something that was dumb
because that's what I know that's what I
can understand I just took the
correlation matrix and I kind of like
took the matrix so all your variables
here are my variables here take the
correlation matrix absolute it we don't
care if it's a negative or positive
correlation and then treat that as an
incidence matrix on a graph and then so
what you have is this like in because
this almost never zero you have this
like strongly connected graph and then
pump up your threshold until like
clusters emerge pick up those clusters
well these clusters are gonna be you
know strongly collinear variables except
that it's even going to do things where
like one thing relates to another
another thing relates to the next you
can get this kind of hold chain going to
you might not pick up if you just like
look immediately at the one at the one
phase relationships and what does it
tell us page count section entropy
that's how many different sections they
visit pages per session days presents
it's all just web usage so all our web
data really amounts to one variable
called how many times a day hit your
website there wasn't enough information
present in any of these other metrics so
here we are like looking at our web logs
thinking oh yeah we got like so much
information 150 columns whatever if it
was like two variables of importance in
the whole thing and this tells me well I
get to in a second the the theme I'm
gonna present here is like getting more
data that it's different from the one
you had is a better use of your time
than perfecting a method there's a lot
to be you and so getting access to data
that you may not even know exists right
now it's probably the best thing you can
do for your problem right now and the
last one was I mentioned this earlier
and if this was a different technique
is just do logistic regression and
increase the l1 penalty I do know the
name of these these plots they're like
follow plots what will happen is that
you're basically forcing more of your
variables to zero as you get closer as
you increase the l1 penalty and when
they two variables drop out at the same
time and importance when their
coefficients go to zero that means
they're correlated because right over
here we got rid of one variable and then
this one was basically representing the
same information so it's a nice
alternative way to see correlated
variables and this thing made sense it's
too small to read but the first two
variables is are you getting the paper
for free because you have some special
pen or whatever - are you on some kind
of like six-month trial it's extremely
disappointing right because we were
hoping to find some like secret nugget
of information that no one knew but it
follows right with your intuitions and
this is maybe like a larger thing which
is when you walk into a place that has
traditional analytics and has people on
the business side who know their
business you're unlikely to find this
like magic crystal ball that they've
been overlooking all these years it's
kind of like an arrogance an academic
arrogance almost that you're gonna go in
with this technique and uncover they've
never seen before if you think about
like the range of variability in
something on one side you've got data
that's like so clear that basically all
I needed to do is plot it and you know
what the thing is on the other side
you've got a lot of variance a lot of
noise you know God knows what's in there
and no technique is going to help you
and so data science exists in the band
between the stuff is obvious and the
stuff that's impossible and that band is
I think a little narrow than I was led
to believe when I got into this thing
okay this is what I learned
black box methods they're great for
demos but real-world problems have a
follow-up step what do we do next
machine learning systems they need to be
treated like engineering systems when
you put something in production you've
really got to treat it like kind of any
other thing and you can treat ml with
the binary on/off miss that you do other
systems I mean a lot of our systems have
thresholds right we have error rates we
can treat machine learning the same way
success in machine learning we can test
out a sample we can treat it with the
production seriousness it deserves it's
not special because it's running a
special algorithm its data in do a lot
of web activity correlates this will not
surprise you you're only data in the
world is web activity you might be
missing out on a lot but we run a brick
and mortar shop too we have calls into
customer service we have a lot of things
that generate footprint outside but I
highly recommend you try to find other
sources when you're interacting with
people who don't have your training you
can often fail really just by not
learning how to speak their language and
this is why at the times we had an
embedding model where you would always
kind of spend a lot of time initially
with the person you're talking to and
adapt your link it's your job to adapt
to them like you have to have the
flexibility to take your generic ideas
of variables and whatever and talk to
the terms that they may have
idiosyncratically developed over the
years in the culture of your company but
expressing it in their terms is often
the difference between having a
cooperative partner and having a person
who feels like who are these people and
also go you know there's a natural
antagony to technocrats who want to walk
in and turn on a machine that replaces
people if you learn to speak people's
language and realize that there is a
gradient between assisting so first
there's advising then there's assisting
then there's send the automation and
there's automation then you can get
around this very real cultural barrier
of the numbers people versus the
business people that's basically the
last the last thing it doesn't mean they
don't think about wrong things folklore
abandons you know and you you there's a
way to prove it without really getting
people's hackles up
all right so the first problem we had
there was about delivering newspapers
I'm intentionally giving a very non
webby kind of example here as long as
people have printed newspapers and put
them on on the sides of doors we've had
to figure out how many newspapers to
drop off sometimes this is outsourced to
distribution companies but the New York
Times actually handles this more or less
ourself and the problem statement is
basically here is a location here's how
many newspapers historically have been
bought at that place and you have to
decide how many to print there's almost
no external data there's like we check
to see like if other variables mattered
it didn't this is a pure time series
problem basically
now you can there's lots of ways you can
dice this you can look at geographic
proximity
we tried that didn't really matter much
sorry this is what the data actually
looks like so you're looking at five
years here this is the number of papers
that were but this is a particularly
poor performing store and I chose that
for a reason because if you have to deal
with problems like this that are
discrete this is like a worst case
scenario zero to one is my response
variable and I'm giving it all these
papers one thing this tells me though is
that there's probably not more demand
than the number of papers I'm giving
them right because these almost never
cross this is the system that was
running when we got there does anyone
know what language this is
no not you yeah it's COBOL it's running
on an as400 and after to admit like the
team had a bit of like arrogance when we
heard about this a is 400 and running
this COBOL thing it was essentially put
together over the course of ten years
it's someone heuristic the heuristics
are basically if the thing is sold out
recently raised the number by one which
is not a bad rule if you actually
simulate this it follows the mean it
adapts within a certain control amount
of time and very importantly it's easy
for a human being to understand and
adjust it and you know
we thought we'd like beat the pants off
this thing the minute we took a modern
method to it and we didn't and that was
like a very important lesson for us that
accumulated wisdom over with people
working with the real problem can often
be a very good result I took some
pictures of our data center you know
we're actually have a crazy stack that
goes everything from from I'm gonna show
you like the air conditions this is an
IBM z10 system I don't it's like and
they get upgraded mainframes are still
around and we still run home delivery on
some of these things right - like the
latest kind of like cloud-based system
but you know it's an entire floor of the
building it's got air conditioning this
is the as/400 you can't really see it
that has been running this this thing
that we were placed and we opened up the
back and we found FedEx envelopes so
like yeah so it looks like really nice
on the outside but you know this thing
has been like the you know gone over by
hackers for a while so when we started
this problem we wanted a kind of a clean
data set to use and the I'm going to
show you some realities of kind of brick
and mortar we have a relationship with
Starbucks is you know like in Starbucks
there's some New York Times there
hopefully and we actually choose right
off my laptop and Anne's laptop right
there sometimes how many papers there
there are available for you and we run
that kind of like every week for the
following week and so it was a nice data
set because the Starbucks is a pretty
good point-of-sale system that can feed
us in relatively rapidly I say
relatively compared to the other
distribution systems where we can wait
up to one month for sales results and
this is maybe one of the things to note
versus an ideal academic scenario is
that we have incredible data lag when
you're dealing with like actual atoms
anyways so we have 20,000 stores to play
with when I got there we had this model
is predicting like hundreds of thousands
of dollars worth of money and this was
done through back testing kind of old
data and I think we had a little too
much confidence in its I mean put in
production it ranked even with this
heuristic algorithm that we'd been like
denigrating like in our heads the whole
time and everyone who I told this
problem to said well have you looked at
seasonality
if one more person tells me to look at
seasonality on this thing so if you so
if you run a seasonality to composition
you will absolutely see something this
is just a linear decomposition you're
always gonna find something that looks
like seasonality but look at that look
at that range
it's like point not point four nine five
two point one five that's not important
the range over here which is the random
you know the stuff that the model can
explain this is just normal our time
time decomposition 0.92 1.2 you know
what this is that's the 2008 election so
this tells me that news events are like
our biggest contributor that we could
possibly control for this is the whole
industry what you're looking at is
people shifting from print to digital in
the in the long-term trend and this
thing I'll tell you why it's not worth
even thinking about it's because we're
in discrete land this is just a sampling
of stores and their distributions and it
looks porcine but look at all the zeros
man there's way too many zeros there's
these this doesn't look with something
this is Poisson plus like another 30%
added to the zero field and I'll tell
you why that is in a second actually
anybody want to guess why in our in our
data we would have a lot of it's
actually I need to show you the data I
take back my my request because I have
to show you more to make the question
clear but it means we shouldn't be using
autoregressive because that's based a
normal distribution whereas a normal
distribution do and it's like close to
one we need to have a Poisson
distribution oh yeah here's the data lag
problem we get on the eighth data for
the previous week to predict for the
following week this means we can't like
we're always going to be our world is
always two years old from the point of
view of the action and that means we
can't take advantage of any short-term
trends so the real trick here is just to
predict a really accurate Poisson mean
you have one problem you can sell out
I'm using shackles because I can't use
real numbers PR told me
but there's math goals there roughly
it's good enough for our purposes
the problem is with inventory problems
is that what do you do when it's sold
out does that mean like no one else
wanted anything or does that mean that
you sold out and somebody was there and
wanted it now cost is 1.5 schmeckle is
two prints a newspaper we get 10.10
chuckles every time we saw one so there
this lost function that's like really
you know it's way more expensive for us
to miss a potential sale so we should
always print more than is there so they
did that but remember the graph from
before I showed you there was like five
years and so they they over you know
bring it back they overdid it because
they they took that advice to heart yeah
so this is all a lot of this is I know
2007 and it's just they're printing way
too many key don't want to miss out
now there's an intangible here which is
the near times always wants you to have
a paper when there's an important news
event we view ourselves as conduits of
information so we have it we will even
lose money to make sure that there's a
paper waiting for you when important
events come when light when like the
Supreme Court ruled on gay marriage we
immediately called all the presses and
like tripled quadrupled the numbers so
there are there are motivations beyond
profit on what we do and that enters our
life so we have to negotiate this kind
of thing between between an ideal
capitalist scenario and these like
external factors okay
so big loss function cost us a lot to
miss a sale we don't know when you miss
a sale so I'm not actually really that
good at math and I went back to school
but I really struggled like doing
differentiating oh my god these lost
functions it was and you shouldn't count
on any like anything that comes out of
me but I do know how to program and this
is something I want to stress is that
you can always run a simulation I did
this one this morning it's probably
reason it was late so let's just walk
through real quickly I wrote it so you
could read it cost equals supply like
how many newspapers we're gonna give you
times the cost cost to make them sales
is the minimum right of demand and the
number newspapers that give so there may
be a demand of four but if I only give
you two you're only gonna sell through
and revenue is going to sales time the
number sales we get
time's the price to sell the rest of
this is just glue to run that over a
data set and the data set is just to
push on random variable so I chose like
a very cool so this is an ideal case
this is a case where we know the true
mean oh sorry
till end oh my god
oh my god I was really worried about
coming up short okay you run this thing
and what happens is if you're off by one
paper you're toast it's fine when you
have like an average of eight papers per
location but on wine you're like really
stuck and it means that there's an upper
bound to how much we can optimize this
problem low counts prediction sucks the
best-case scenario is you're gonna be
off by like an average of one because
that's how Poisson works I don't
recommend it so we did our best if it
turns out to be a classic problem we
decompose it into like cases where we
knew that abandoned didn't its ran into
a problem we were trying to do an
experiment so we initially thought we'll
just have control on treatment groups
cuz we're not gonna even trust that our
simulations are correct but then stores
started dropping out they can do this
and this would have ruined a normal
experiment worse it's actually uneven
what if one of these like large sale
people dropped out so our experiment
would gone out the window
but we revised the to use matched pairs
we match these things on previous
previous sales data so if we lost
something in the control group we had a
treatment group to to do and it's
accelerated so much so when we started
it was taking us six months to come to
the coop yes six months to come to a
conclusion we increased sample size got
our stuff together as far as
experimental design and now we're
running three experience in the same
time and you can see we finally got one
finally got one to beat the heuristic
and then we found out that that's they
didn't just want to optimize for profit
which is a nice problem solved for so
they wanted a few papers for various
other reasons there so we said look
let's just give you a knob you can have
a knob and you can like add a few papers
here and there but you'd stay in this
range we told them where the profit
range was and this is I guess kind of
the thing is it's unsatisfying but in
the end we made something whereby we got
the best optimal solution and we also
kind of satisfied the client need to
have a little bit of control over what
they're doing
it's their business after all you can't
just plop an algorithm and say here you
go find something else to do okay you
can read that later I'm
turns out this problem was trying to
solve was also tried to solve in like
2001 and back then we could tie web so
we could actually look at web traffic
and adjust the print run for the next
day and it was quite successful okay you
know speed through this but I feel it's
really important it's a little
philosophical what I noticed after about
a year is that we were trying to find
problems for the data we knew about it
just totally backwards right if you're
running a lemonade stands you don't like
you know solve eye discounts on the
lemonade powder when your location is
bad you have to like figure what the
business is telling you and there's a
bit of a bitter tendency sometimes to
font used to be a bias to success and it
causes I think a bit of distortion in
the type of problems the data science is
solving because they're not they're not
like saying okay let's start putting
metrics on this let's figure what's most
important for the company and it's
because of friction
let's get that so this is a question for
people over here how many people outside
your data science and engineering team
can honestly ask questions of your data
and I mentioned this is the kind of
person who can debug a Hadoop stack
trace exactly not the person who knows
the business dynamics and I think
there's more value in expanding the
number of people can participate in the
conversation meaningfully than by
enabling the experts programmers are
fine they've always found ways to get
around kind of technical barriers
they'll solve but can you enable people
who don't who work in Excel and maybe a
little bit of sequel and get them
involved in the conversation because
they're much closer to the product and
they have better instincts than your
technical people data so what I saw is
we kind of need to expand the number of
people can participate and lower the
relative skill level I'll skip that
let's skip that
so what are the barriers to casual use
you can read that but it's dumb stuff
and I eventually switched from kind of
data science to doing data engineering
for a while this was a prioritization I
thought was really important we had that
stable infrastructure it had you had
that sequel that's like a no don't get
me SPARC don't get me all this stuff as
soon as you say you need to have like an
IDE you're ruling out like twice as many
people at your company you could be
participating and it also helps the
people who can do SPARC right
google has sequel access to all their
data for reason they want people to be
productive these are three of our most
valued people you think they're like
solving some like a really deep problem
and this is what they're staring at we
bought a million dollar Hadoop cluster
and we chucked it a year later because
we just could not get the thing stable
enough for a lot of our business use
okay this is a quote I'm I'm gonna sound
like a shill for Google but I swear to
god we end up choosing bigquery and
Google because we can't compete in the
labor market for the number of data
engineers required to keep an analytic
stack to service an organization of our
size happy we can get it
but there's always somebody unhappy and
I think there's gonna be a shift
happening we're finally at the stage
that we can actually amortize the cost
of hard problems to cloud providers and
we can rent them Google just is has a
Google as an internal product called
spanner which does global transactions
they did it by putting atomic clocks in
every data center we're not going to do
that but we could use global
transactions and I think this is what's
gonna happen cloud providers until now
have emulated private data centers but
what happens when the cloud providers
you know end up buying 75% of all the
CPUs in the world so this is oh yeah
this is on-ramp let's say you're just
someone who's not in analytics not on
data and you just want to like play with
the data it's very useful to have a web
interface whatever DB you have make them
some web interface for it okay yep
it skip skip skip worth it staff yeah
some make it easy to join this is Ann's
code rewritten for like the new systems
you're not going to compete in the job
market when GE starts getting into the
software game so we have to lower the
barrier to entry to get at the data so I
guess I'll conclude a little early here
but my basic point is those people who
have good ideas and maybe they don't use
the sophisticated tools as you if you
make them productive for the information
solve the problems with privacy solve
the problems with cumbersome data stacks
you're going to start seeing bation
happening at the places where it counts
not in a handful of experts but in a
more democratic fashion anyways that's
right Stan thanks very much